SEAN HANNITY TAKES OVER NOW.
>> Sean: TUCKER, THANK YOU,
AND WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT FOR THE HOUR WE'RE TO
HIGHLIGHT THE SERIOUS DEVICE A
PROBLEM THAT PERSISTS ALL OF
THIS COUNTRY, MAINLY AMONG
DEMOCRATS, THEIR FRIENDS, AND
BIG TECH, THE MEDIA MOB.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN, THESE
POWERFUL INDIVIDUALS -- AND THEY
ARE POWERFUL -- THEY CREATE
RULES THEY THEMSELVES DON'T
FOLLOW.
SOME CALL IT HYPOCRISY, OTHERS
REFER TO IT AS A DOUBLE
STANDARD.
IN REALITY, IT'S FRAUD,
DECEPTION, FOR THE PURPOSE OF
POLITICAL GAIN IN POWER.
IT'S ABOUT FORCING YOUR KIDS TO
WEAR MASKS DURING RECESS EVEN
WHILE ADULTS PACK INTO A CROWDED
ARENA, NOT A MASK INSIGHT.
IT'S ABOUT TWITTER AND FACEBOOK,
THEY CENSOR THE VERY TRUE HUNTER
BIDEN LAPTOP REPORT WHILE
ALLOWING THE FAKE SALACIOUS
CLAIMS IN THE DIRTY DOSSIER, THE
RUSSIAN DIRTY DOSSIER THAT
HILLARY PAID FOR.
THAT COULD CIRCULATE ALL DAY,
EVERY DAY, EVERY PLACE.
IT'S ABOUT JOE ROGAN BECOMING
ENEMY NUMBER ONE FOR HAVING AN
OPEN DIALOGUE AND DARING TO ASK
QUESTIONS THAT I GUESS ARE
INAPPROPRIATE.
RACHEL MADDOW?
SHE FACES ZERO REPERCUSSIONS FOR
DELIBERATELY LYING TO HER
VIEWERS ABOUT, OH, TRUMP/RUSSIA
COLLUSION FOR HOW MANY YEARS?
HAS ABOUT FIX NEW CNN
OBSESSIVELY CONDEMNING
JANUARY 6TH, THE RIOT THAT TOOK
PLACE, BUT THEN NEVER TALKING
ABOUT THE 574 RIOTS IN THE
SUMMER OF 2020 THAT LEFT DOZENS
OF PEOPLE DEAD.
THEY CHARACTERIZED THOSE RIGHTS
IS MOSTLY PEACEFUL, EVEN WHEN
THE CITY IS BURNING BEHIND THEIR
REPORTER RIGHT OVER THE
SHOULDER.
IT'S ABOUT WHOOPI GOLDBERG.
RECENTLY MAKING COMMENTS ABOUT
THE HOLOCAUST, MINIMIZED THE
HORRORS OF WHAT WAS RACIST.
HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LET'S BE TRUTHFUL ABOUT IT
BECAUSE THE HOLOCAUST ISN'T
ABOUT RACE.
NO.
IT'S NOT ABOUT RACE.
>> WELCOME IT IS --
>> IT'S NOT ABOUT RACE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT RACE.
>> THAN WHAT IS IT ABOUT?
>> IT'S ABOUT MAN'S INHUMANITY
TO MAN.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
>> BUT IT'S ABOUT WHITE
SUPREMACY.
[OVERTOP]
>> THESE ARE WHITE GROUPS OF
PEOPLE.
>> DOMINIC YOU'RE MISSING THE
POINT.
THE MINUTE YOU TURN IT INTO
RACE, IT GOES DOWN THIS ALLEY.
>> Sean: SHE WAS RIGHT ON THE
EVIL PORTION OF HER COMMENTS,
BUT OF COURSE SHE WAS WRONG AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.
SHE AND HAS SINCE ACKNOWLEDGED,
RIGHTFULLY APOLOGIZED, CLARIFIED
HER REMARKS, BUT THINK ABOUT
THIS.
IT WILL BE GOLDBERG WERE A
CONSERVATIVE OR A REPUBLICAN,
WOULDN'T SHE BE FIRED ALREADY OR
THE VERY LEAST BE BOMBARDED WITH
BOYCOTTS AND SERIOUS
REPERCUSSIONS?
ON THIS PROGRAM IT OVER THE
ENTIRE COURSE OF MY CAREER I
HAVE STEADFASTLY REFUSED TO JOIN
CALLS TO BOYCOTT AND FIRE AND
HAVE PEOPLE CANCELED.
LOOK, I'VE KNOWN WHOOPI GOLDBERG
FOR YEARS.
WE HAVEN'T TALKED RECENTLY, I
WILL SAY THAT, HAVEN'T GONE BACK
ON THE SHOW IN A LONG TIME, AND
WE NEVER AGREED POLITICALLY.
I SIMPLY SEE HER BEING
INARTICULATE AND MAYBE NOT EVEN
UNDERSTANDING THE EVIL IDEOLOGY
THAT WAS HITLER AND
NAZI GERMANY.
SHE'S NOT ANTI-SEMITIC FROM THE
PERSON THAT I KNEW.
I READ PEOPLE PRETTY WELL.
IT'S OBVIOUS HER COMMENTS WERE
GROSSLY INACCURATE.
SHE HAS RIGHTLY APOLOGIZED,
SHE'S CLARIFIED HER REMARKS.
I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE I'M OLD-FASHIONED, I JUST
BELIEVE IN SECOND CHANCES, AND
I'M PRETTY CONFIDENT SHE'S NEVER
GOING TO MAKE THAT SAME MISTAKE
AGAIN.
YEAH, AND I KNOW NOBODY AT THE
VIEW WOULD EVER DO THIS FOR A
CONSERVATIVE EVER.
HELL WOULD FREEZE OVER, BUT
HERE'S THE GREAT THING ABOUT
LIVING IN A FREE COUNTRY, IF YOU
DON'T LIKE WHAT WHOOPI GOLDBERG
SAID, GUESS WHAT?
CHANGE THE CHANNEL.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE HER SHOW,
YOU DON'T LIKE STEPHEN COLBERT,
CONSTANTLY SHOWING FOR
DEMOCRATS, TELLING BAD JOKES,
DON'T WATCH IT.
NO ONE IS FORCING YOU TO.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TUNE IN.
CENSORSHIP VIA BIG GOVERNMENT,
CORPORATIONS, IS NEVER THE
ANSWER.
TONIGHT I'M CALLING ON EVERYONE,
ON ALL THESE OTHER NETWORKS HERE
ON ABC, NBC, CBS, MSDNC, FAKE
NEW CNN, YOU NEED TO DENOUNCE
CENSORSHIP AND STOP WITH THE
BOYCOTTS AND STOP WITH THE FAINT
MORAL OUTRAGE AND NONE OF YOUR
PERFECT EITHER, AND WHEN YOU
MAKE A MISTAKE, YOU SHOULD GET
THE SAME FORGIVENESS IF YOU'RE
SINCERE IN YOUR APOLOGY.
THAT'S NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN.
DISHONESTY HACKS.
YOU KNOW, THE HUMPTY DUMPTY'S OF
THE WORLD.
THEY LOVE CENSORSHIP.
THEY WANT FOX OFF THE AIR, THEY
WANT CONSERVATIVES ON TALK RADIO
SILENCE.
THEY WANT REPUBLICANS OUT OF
POWER FOREVER, AND THEY DETEST
EVEN THE SITE OF DONALD TRUMP.
THEY DETEST COMPETITION,
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THEY ARE
LOSING SO BADLY.
SO THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT TRUTH,
FAIRNESS, FREEDOM, FORGIVENESS,
NONE OF THAT.
THAT'S WHY JUST A FEW HOURS
AFTER JOE ROGAN APOLOGIZED,
WHICH I DON'T THINK HE SHOULD
HAVE DONE, FOR POTENTIALLY
SPREADING MISINFORMATION, THE
MEDIA CONTINUED TO ATTACK HIM.
IN JOE ROGAN'S CASE, I'M ARGUING
HE DIDN'T NEED TO APOLOGIZE AT
ALL.
THE LEFT WANTS TO SQUASH ALL